back folks Chris waters here on the
stage at gamespot's III booth covering
it live 2014 joining me now Alex and
[ __ ] Dominic mange to talk about
entwined a game that I think came as a
surprise to many during the sony press
conference one of the few that wasn't
leaked it was marvelous and also you
know the sony press conference was these
swings i think from a different type dif
different genres of games different
types of games different art styles and
and the swing into entwined was just
lovely yes have you guys I how's it been
to have it out there I was so exciting
to be part of the conference and to be
able to announce and then lawns at the
same time because we then wouldn't think
many games have done that before so you
did the launch I can I know I that you
whenever those announcements are made
they're always exciting to be like oh we
could get this game now then I realized
there I'm like here for the next week so
today don't have quite the impact but
entwined is available now but you guys
just announced it and people are getting
their first look at it yeah so yeah I
mean what a great opportunity to be part
of the press conference and show the
game and then be able to say straight
away and you can actually buy it right
now it's a much more game a friendly way
of getting your games out there yeah
especially in this digital age right why
can't we do that so we've got the game
here and we're at we've got someone
playing backstage we're just going to go
ahead and jump right in are we starting
from the beginning of the game where we
sort of so we've got Alex back stage is
our producer and I think he's going to
be playing starting from level 2 but we
should probably get Jang the designer to
talk a little bit about the game yeah
all right so Jing we're now we sort of
saw the eye we got a got a demo a little
bit from Dominic during the press
conference but talk to us a bit sort of
set the stage for these these two
creatures that we see flying through
space so it's based on like
no Chinese ancient story about fishing
birthday post the original together as
one and there's also some folk lore
about fish timberland in love but
couldn't be together because one live in
the sky and one leap in the water so our
game is about them trying to find each
other through nine lifetime of
reincarnation and through this process
the player help them to combine together
as one dragon edn and he sort of you
know right from the start they they are
combined in a way because the player is
controlling them both with one
controller so how does that how does
that control scheme work sort of what
was the motivation to make it let that
control so we used to have a two player
a prototype and we found out oh how he
shouldn't do a multiplayer because it's
the audience might not be as much as big
a single player so we try it like one
player control to your character and we
built a prototype that control to dodd
other side and we find out it's kind of
confusing if the left dot go to the
right so we suffer the screen into half
as when the story come in because they
couldn't touch each other sure yeah so
it works gameplay wise and within the
within the story within the myth so you
know I think quotes are watching they
can see you know you're trying to sort
of sweeping through these these wedges
some some of them you fly through
together some of the mean muscat capture
with one side or the other I what is the
kind of game play experience you're
trying to create it's more like a
symmetric kind of experience so we want
it to be like when you're using your
left brain you also use your right brain
and because the music and artists so
abstract so wanted to evolve people's
personal memory
and get Ibaka Pisces experience and
mesmerized by it so like suck into the
middle of the screen and lost himself
and then there's their own memories and
I think any time I experienced this last
year playing a game called brothers a
tale of two sons which you control two
different characters one with each
control signal you kind of do have to
get yourself mesmerised you kind of have
to get your brain into thinking in these
two these two parts so which are
separate but but you know coming from
you coming from one person it have you
did you have any sort of sort of trouble
finding the sweet spot of controls and
how to design the levels around that at
the beginning we have some like hard to
control ones and we didn't figure out
like how to match the circle so like
people are flicking joysticks so later
we find out maybe we'll ask them to push
it outside and then rosso image exactly
to the circle outside so that's the part
we find like haha it begins the circle
kind of maps to the you know that the
range of the joystick itself so it's
kind of helps you I guess we've got a
lot of people curious about the game so
I'm going to take a question from
Twitter here ma KU soo anaki wants to
know well first of all says its wine
looks awesome I'm also going to ask if
there you know this this sort of level
is an aesthetic is tron like in their
words but deep you guys sort of what
kind of other aesthetics do you take on
I mean actually we're sort of seeing a
bit of a change here what's the artistic
approach to the game here Oh although
can we just put that a question on hold
and tell me what's happening right now
cuz we become the dragon right so within
each lifetime you get the chance to
bring the two characters together and
when you do they transform into this
incredible dragon which is meant to be a
real high point and a reward for the
challenge that you've had in the level
and it's a time for the players to
express themselves when you pick up the
the the collectibles now it's actually
building up this meter and it turns into
living paint so you can create your own
aerial sculptures as you fly around and
everyone gets to make their own one and
we're really hoping that people use the
ps4 share button to share their own
unique creations it's very abstract you
know idea but we wanted the moment when
they come together and the
dragon to represent something really
important because it's the tooth finally
getting to be together absolutely yeah
and you know what actually that the
whole sort of sculpture I guess we'll
see it in a second here but you speaking
of it reminds me of when I would play
flower and get a large tail and just
just spend time sort of intertwining
myself and trying to make a make like a
little sculpture in the air makes make
sort of shapes and such as that stuff
like that so is that what the dragon is
our coding right now yeah and is it
leaving those green streaks you see or
those RT and oh I see so sort of these
are it's like a paintbrush yes
exactement and each level has a very
different type of paint and you'll see
when when when Alex finishes his his his
own unique sculpture animals would come
out of the paint so the idea is that the
paint is alive and it's bringing these
creatures out of the environment and
then they go and create the exit for you
and they all ride on a ferris wheel and
have a good time I so I guess that gets
back to the question we were asking
earlier is and you know if there's
different kinds of paint I are there
different I you know what is the the
visual difference between levels what
kind of aesthetics and did you sort of
play with from D call the levels
lifetime we call them lifetimes yeah
from a lifetime to lifetime what a
that's a very poetic way to refer to
them there's nine different lifetimes
that you play through and each one has a
very different emotional feel at its
core and that's influenced the art style
so I'd in the third lifetime here the
emotion that we're trying to evoke is
solitude and loneliness so it's a nice
level it's cold there's a unique
soundtrack that I compose the sam
marshall is composed for every level and
the sound design also changes as well so
our sound designer greg went in and
created a unique tone that is played
every time you go through an obstacle
haha and it allows you to sort out
you're contributing to the soundtrack so
there's like it there's a note that
plays each time you go through and
that's another part of immersing you and
these different sensations and feelings
so there's a huge variety and look and
feel that you go through in each level
and right at the very beginning of the
process when we're in pre-production
Jing put together this amazing emotional
contour that we want the players to go
through
and that was really the beginning of
that process of figuring out what each
level was going to look like what it was
going to sound like and then it just
became this big loop of collaboration
between the teams to figure it all out
seems like it seems very telling of what
kind of game you guys are trying to
create that almost the design document
for the game was an emotional contour
not a feature list or anything any
anything like that absolutely uh I you
know I noticed before just in the very
beginning of the level the blue the bird
was sort of missed a few of the the
objects that it was just trying to
collect there's a bit of a red so and we
saw like a little jarring there on the
fish side what is the you know if you're
not so good if you're having a little
trouble getting all the the sphere or
getting all the running into all the the
objects what is the the player feedback
can you can you fail a lifetime how does
that work if you fail one obstacle you
lose some of the bar you see the boss
the calexico they represent the memory
between the two lovers so when you when
you hit something you kind of lose the
collectible and with a clock for bars
for you just are there in twining mode
that transform into the dragon okay we
don't die in the story mode but like it
go your progress get kicks that a little
bit but it's still just take a take
longer to get to that from culmination
point there's also you know one of the
things we noticed when we were focused
test in the game is that people tend to
grasp the idea of the coordination at
different points and so the game
actually has a dynamic difficulty curve
that's attached to that as well so as
you were going through the stages that
Jing was talking about and powering up
and powering down it also moves you on
some more or less challenging sequences
of obstacles to fly through and we
really wanted to make sure that
everybody no matter what your skill
level can play through the entire story
mode and enjoy all of the things that
it's trying to bring to you and so
hopefully as you get better then you get
familiar and more instinctive with the
controls it will match that with more
interesting obstacles for you to fly
three yeah do you guys put that put that
skill ceiling up a little bit higher
make it pretty challenging for challenge
the dexterity of players and there's
also this is the story mode but there's
also a challenge mode as well that is
just the
pure mechanic distilled into its most
challenging form and it's kind of like
an endless runner you have to stay alive
through five there's five different
elemental challenges and you have to
stay alive as long as you possibly can
but you only have three lives to make
mistakes and you get a little sort of
leaderboard challenge yeah absolutely
that version will also be available
later on as iOS and Android version t.o
interesting so entwined not only out now
on the PlayStation 4 but ps3 and Vita
about a month and then shortly after
that we're going to launch the challenge
mode on iOS and Android T is that going
to be holding your thumb sorta on either
side of the touchscreen all right very
nice well we are gett getting very close
to transforming into the dragon here
we'll take a look at the sort of
aesthetic that comes once you we break
out of this tunnel of solitude and cold
foreboding visuals I didn't do these
does the fish have a name so the bird
have a name you guys uh no good 81 I
know Brittany I think I know you have
names for them you call them when you
play it all you guys I don't I don't you
know it is interesting we talks a lot
about how specific which should we get
with the narrative in this story and I
think we both agreed we wanted to leave
it abstract and not go and fill in those
details so that everybody else can paint
their own ideas over the top where they
can all finish the thought gamers can
finish the idea on their own so it means
different things to different people
yeah especially when you're going to you
know you're focusing on evoking emotions
that's so personal for any for anyone
who's playing it so giving them room to
to put themselves in there yeah it's
important and here we are in sort of an
Arctic feeling yeah space and uh oh nice
I always look like no matter what game
it's in I love that effect of when
you're flying and you get close to the
water and slaughtered H sort of thrills
up and I so is this actually is this
part can you sort of motion control this
guy using the using the tilt sensors and
such no you can't it's still twin sticks
haha but this time because you're
together you coordinate in the same
direction and so that that idea of them
coming
together and unifying actually changes
in the controls as well so you're moving
in unison yeah your two thumbs in
harmony yeah very cool all right we're
gonna see some painting in the sky here
oh yeah I entwined available now coming
soon to on ps4 available now in peaceful
is for coming soon on ps3 and Vita and
then a little bit after that iOS and
Android as well very cool I you guys
been have people been able to get their
hands on it here on the show floor it's
getting to see people play it how's that
been so excited to see people play and
then get just you lost themselves
completely you wanna put a song in when
you talk to them it has noticed oh yeah
so much I'm just do I think that means
you did a really good job Dominic Jing
thank you so much for coming up entwine
here on our stage when hope III
continues to be fruitful for both of you
and folks we're going to be coming back
to the live stage show here Danny
O'Dwyer is coming out and there's going
to be some dance central spot light out
here I'm not sure if Danny's gonna dance
but I hope so I'll be back later this
afternoon with some more demos but for
now Danny's going to take over stick
with us as gamespot's coverage of e3
continues